all right first up nicola founder trevor
milton has been charged with three
counts of fraud we've been talking about
a trevor milton and the company nikola
for a long time as it's an eevee startup
or hydrogen slash ev startup
and we had him on episode 1090 so you
can go watch that original episode or
it's linked to in the show
notes but here is the cnbc quote a
federal grand jury charged nicola
founder trevor milton with three
three counts of criminal fraud for lying
about nearly all aspects of
the business so
he was lying about and this was in
quotes
nearly all aspects of the business to
bolster stock sales of the electric
vehicle startup according to an
indictment unsealed on thursday milton
resigned as chairman in september after
fraud allegations surfaced and
our friends at hindenburg research
dropped a bombshell
report here is the quote from u.s
attorney audrey
strauss from a press briefing this
morning
this is a very straightforward case
milton told lies to
generate popular demand for nicola stock
beginning at least
in or about march 2020 when nicola
announced that its stock
would become public listed milton became
increasingly preoccupied with keeping
nicholas stock price
high that's her quote and we saw that if
you watch the episode
nikola stock is down another nine
percent today
yet somehow it's still at a five billion
dollar market cap who is
who are the bag holders here and what
are you thinking even if you lost 90
cents on the dollar that
10 cents if you made a bet on a company
that goes 10 or 20 x
you could get whole and you could get
maybe double your money back all money
has value
when you're losing this badly get up
from the table take your chips and go
find another game to play in
so remember when i interviewed him back
on episode 1090
trevor was all over the place and people
asked me what my goal was there in the
interview
i kind of got the sense that this could
be a scam and that this guy was full of
ish and i just said you know what i'm
gonna take the approach
of letting him talk because
if something is a fraud the more the
person talks the better the audience and
myself can get an idea of
is this person legit in other words a
criminal a sociopath a fraud
is going to reveal themselves if you can
just get them to talk
so that is what i did and when i asked
him about his product
he said that the company went public so
they wouldn't develop the problems that
we work had
that was a little bit of a weird red
flag okay you're
describing yourself as somehow the
counter to wework and he was very
focused on the stock price in the ipo as
a product as opposed to the product he
was selling
and there were a bunch of letters intent
there was just a lot of smoke here
and we covered his resignation on
episode
1112 after fraud allegations from
a hindenburg research claimed nicola was
an
ocean of lies here's a one-minute clip
i'll talk to you another side
mark controls facebook but he has a
really good bright brilliant team around
him that balances him
and there was never that over there and
that's what i've done here nicolas we
built this team this really good balance
around people that are
objective they'll tell me no they'll
tell me yes they'll tell me whatever i
need
whatever's honest they'll tell me and
they're a great balance to me
and we've created this company now that
is it's over 10 billion dollars today
by the years in my opinion i can't tell
anyone where it's going to go but i
believe it'll be
three to four to five times that we and
that's a great thing about being public
is as soon as you start executing your
vision
it just starts it just starts going
crazy and that's where we're at so we
let the retail investors come in
you hit on this point earlier most
people wait
until it's too late for retail investors
to ever get involved
we allow retail investors to come in
and they get to ride the ride with us
now it's very volatile but they get to
ride the ride with us and that's the
advantage it's not just
big humongous funds that are buying all
your stock and they get all the upside
the regular person gets to be part of
the nikola story now and that's a brand
new model that no one's ever really done
before until now
okay so he's referring to spax and
getting the company out early
before it has product market fit before
it really has customers
when it has these fugazi letters of
intent and
letters of intent are for me are just
pieces of paper they literally
are worth the paper they're printed on
which i think paper costs a penny
a page or something like that these days
maybe two cents so it's
absolutely worthless and this is the
perfect example of why
you are responsible for your investments
you are responsible for doing your
diligence because he is telling you in
this video
he thinks he can go 345x and that you
get to become along for the ride and
that he's doing you a favor
and all of that sounds really convincing
you listen to him talking about this
remember founders sociopaths they all
index for convincing people
charismatic people serial killers all
very charismatic
and he is basically doing a real sale
job there on
people who are new entrants to the
markets and who
wanted to participate in their company
the company which still hasn't earned
any revenue from what i understand is
trying to distance itself
from trevor here's the quote from nicola
treva milton
resigned on september 20 2020 and has
not been involved in the company's
operations or communication since that
time today's government
actions are against mr milton
individually not against the cops i
guess they're trying to
keep this boat afloat the federal
indictment
states that milton engaged in a
fraudulent scheme to deceive retail
investors
in his own interest which he kind of
telegraphed on the show here's a minute
46 i'll see on the side
so now you've got all this cash on the
balance sheet
and you've got all this runway but you
this building a network of hydrogen
chargers
and coordinating the building of
hydrogen trucks and
satisfying a bunch of customers seems
like an awful lot of work
and that i'm not sure exactly the date
you announced it what date did you
announce that you're gonna
take on ford's f-150 pickup truck and
elon cybertruck and the riven
riven is uh vivian sorry so now you
decide
f it i'm going to create an f-150 the
best-selling car
uh in the united states i think and
obviously the best-selling truck
why would you take on more work
that's a good question yeah so here's
the reason why our trucks are a gravy
train with money that's where all the
money comes from
is our big semi trucks right the problem
is 90 of americans will never own a semi
truck
and so your investment for your
investment your portfolio of investors
can be very limited
and we wanted to go and build a company
that's going to be worth 500 billion
trillion dollars over say 10 or 10 or 15
years and if you're limiting yourself to
10 percent of the market you'll never do
it
all right so a couple of things there
just one on interview technique and it's
interesting to see me
see yourself interviewing somebody who
then turns out to be a fraud and i
had this like this guy's full of ish
full of it and
a lot of times i will ask a question on
this show
and when you see me doing questions
where it will seem like i'm
confused and in reality i may or may not
be confused there are times when i am
actually confused and i'm asking your
founder hey explain this thing about
nfts to me or explain to me your
cryptocurrency
project i don't get a synthetic biology
there are things i
genuinely do not know about and when i
ask a question and i say i don't
understand this i don't
but there are sometimes i'll ask a
question and
it'll seem like i'm confused and this is
a specific technique i use
to allow the guest to then
educate me and by extension you the
audience and part of this community
that's what you just saw there i'm using
a technique of saying listen
i'm a little confused here you you're
creating this business it seems really
hard isn't that an art business
and then you can take on this other
thing it's like a lot of work
and this is colombo if you've ever seen
colombo
the detective he has very basic
questions and he seems like he's a
bumbling fool sometimes
that's what that's literally the
technique i'm channeling there is
can you explain this to me and he does
and the explanation is probably going to
be in this indictment or
some lawyer who winds up suing is going
to pull this specific clip
hey everybody harryhurst yes the co-ceo
and co-founder of
pipe.com is with us and he's going to
explain to you how pipe.com works and
what a great innovation it is
for startups many of my startups are
using it harry welcome to the show
thank you jason so tell us what is pipe
net and for people don't know it's
pipe.com
great domain pipe's a trading platform
and we allow companies to turn their
recurring revenue streams
into upfront capital and they do that by
trading those recurring revenue streams
with
institutional investors that are on the
other side of our marketplace
and they're looking to purchase the
annual value of those subscription
revenues
so companies can reinvest that capital
into growth or whatever initiative
they'd like
without having to take on dilution and
you've probably seen we've been called
the
the nasdaq for revenue all right thanks
again harry and with pipe there's no
debt no loans and no dilution which is
really important to me as an investor
pipe and harry are so confident you're
gonna love trading your recurring
revenues that if you sign up at pipe.com
twist today they'll eliminate all your
trading fees for one
full year what a generous offer this
could save you tens of thousands of
dollars depending on the size of your
business and the volume you trade sign
up today at pipe.com
twist happy piping everybody